meanwhile nearly half of Americans
believe the corona virus pandemic is
affecting their mental health 19 percent
say it's having a major impact according
to a CBS poll psychologist and CBS News
contributor Lisa d'amour joins us now
from Cleveland to answer your questions
about the virus and mental health Lisa
good morning let's begin with I think
the most common mental health challenge
out there and that is Americans facing
depression viewer on Instagram asks what
advice you have for people who are right
now alone as a shelter-in-place
and suffering from long-term depression
good morning and I'm so glad that we're
answering these questions so when we
think about depression the first thing
we need to remember is that this is a
treatable mental illness but what people
may not know is that they can get
treatment right now even under stay at
home conditions typically telehealth is
something that requires a special
license something where if we're going
to work with people digitally but under
the current conditions those regulations
have been relaxed states and insurance
companies are working to make sure that
people can get mental health care so if
you or someone you love needs to work
with somebody for support reach out
through your normal referral channels
maybe your general practitioner or your
employer find yourself a good mental
health clinician and start working with
them now from home and then you can
follow up with them in person when
things return to normal the other thing
I would say right now is that we need to
be really careful about how we are
coping with this weather we have mental
health concerns
prior to this or not we want to watch
out for negative coping strategies so
any coping strategy offers relief but
negative coping strategies don't work
well over the long run so don't allow
yourself to emotionally isolate don't
count on substances to manage hard
feelings don't let yourself fall into
bad habits about not sleeping enough or
becoming sedentary instead we want to
turn to positive coping strategies
whenever we can reach out to other
people use happy distractions to manage
emotional discomfort find yourself ways
to make sure you're getting enough sleep
getting enough X
is getting outdoors when you can those
positive coping strategies are going to
make a huge difference
Lisa we've also got a question on
Facebook from Remley who regularly uses
meditation and other techniques to
manage her anxiety and but now she feels
her skills are no longer useful and she
asks what can I do to get this in check
great question so everyone's anxiety is
a little bit heightened right now and
that's a normal reaction I don't want
people to feel anxious if they're
feeling anxious that's appropriate right
now but if you feel like your normal
strategies for regulating your anxiety
are not working well what I would say to
everybody is that it's time to up your
breathing game and here's what I mean
when we are highly anxious our brain
sends a message to our heart and our
lungs to speed activity and this is
actually rooted in the ancient fighter
flight system but it's physically
uncomfortable that's what we experience
as uncomfortable anxiety it turns out
that our lungs can actually send a
message back to our brain our lungs are
covered with a network of nerves that
detect the activity of the brain of the
of the lungs of how quickly and deeply
we are breathing so if you deliberately
slow and deepen your breathing it
actually speaks to those nerves those
stretch receptors on your lungs and
sends a reassuring message back up to
the brain to sort of calm the anxiety
response so I know it can seem like
everybody talks about breathing and it
may be seem sort of small or like not a
bigot or intervention but in fact
careful and slow and deep breathing can
significantly reduce anxiety yeah at
least so that's great advice I mean
sometimes the simple things are the most
powerful things I want to sneak in one
more question here from a viewer named
Carol who asks something that I think
many of us are thinking about as we look
ahead to a time when this virus is is
gone and we can get back to something
like normal and her question is will she
ever enjoy being around strangers again
and not feel threatened this is an
interesting one because under normal
conditions the rule is that avoidance
feeds anxiety that if you have a fear
you have to face it to get past it but
right now the guidance is avoid everyone
everything and that is the right healthy
safety thing to do to really stay home
and to be very cautious about going out
when things go back to normal there may
be some people who feel frightened about
returning to life as it was before and
that will be the time for them to face
their fears the good news here is that
they don't have it all at once they can
do it in baby steps
Lisa got it baby steps a lot of us are
doing baby steps these days sue from
facebook says her family's starting to
get agitated with one another and wants
to know when will the bickering be over
what solutions can you recommend about
that for families to get along and
there's an article in USA Today where it
says yelling and spanking is up in homes
these days can you address those sure so
we're all in close quarters and people
are getting on one another's nerves so
if you can find space take a break you
should do it we have to remember that
when it comes to bickering it takes to
to bicker so just some because somebody
tosses something at you doesn't mean you
have to catch it you can refuse to
engage that way or you can say to them
start again I would say for families
with kids they may see a lot of
bickering right now and some of that may
be how kids are trying to manage boredom
kids have a lot of time on their hands
and sometimes siblings will manage their
boredom by like starting something with
one of their siblings so if you think
this might be happening I would just
call it on the carpet and I would just
say look you might be bored but
antagonizing your sister is not the
solution to that problem like go find
something else to do at least the decor
I think that's a great piece of advice
to end on and I would only add that if
you're one of those Americans still
lucky enough to have a job and you're
trying to do it from home a little
forgiveness you're not going to be as
productive as efficient as capable as
you might have been when you're going to
an office everything is disrupted so
just forgive yourself Lisa thank you
very much